là il pourrait évoquer cette situation
autour de Mario Paul notre chroniqueur
international Bruno Darou nous a rejoint
au plateau bonjour Bruno bonjour Antoine
Bruno on l'a vu donc nouvelle échec
encore une fois de l'évacuation de Mario
Paul des civils de Mario Paul russe et
ukrainiens qui se renvoie la balle en
une certaine manière qui s'accuse
mutuellement la situation peut vite
devenir intenable notamment pour les
civils Bruno dans la ville alors selon
le HR notamment la situation humanitaire
de Mario Paul est déjà extrêmement
alarmante les les habitants manquent
d'eau manque de nourriture il y a des
coupures d'électricité il y a les
coupures donc de chauffage donc
situation très dur pour les 420 000
habitants de cette cité stratégique donc
sur la mer d'Azov hier déjà il y avait
eu l'espoir d'un premier corridor
humanitaire mais il y avait eu pareil
des accusations des deux côtés qui avait
fait que l'évacuation de civil n'avait
pas pu avoir lieu aujourd'hui
c'est à nouveau le cas c'est-à-dire que
les deux camps on vient de le voir
s'accusent mutuellement de ne pas créer
les les circonstances propices à une
évacuation sereine de quelques 200 000
civils quand même donc c'est énorme
alors le HR lui essaye de faire les
médiateurs et il dit qu'il s'agit il
suffit pas de se mettre d'accord sur le
principe d'un corridor humanitaire il
faut ensuite aller dans le détail
c'est-à-dire respecter de part et
d'autre les horaires d'évacuation se
mettre extrêmement d'accord sur les
itinéraires d'évacuation et ça pourrait
déjà aider
à éviter ces violations de cesser le feu
qui font qu'à chaque fois l'évacuation
de ces civils est stoppée un mot
également avec vous rapidement Bruno
vous l'avez évoqué mais Mario Paul donc
c'est une ville stratégique si les
forces russes arrivent à prendre la
ville et à faire la jonction avec ce les
autres forces venues du don-basse ce
serait un coût majeur pour les pour les
Russes dans cette guerre oui enfin ce
serait un cou majeur dans leur
progression territoriale dans cette zone
de l'Ukraine ça leur permettrait
effectivement de faire la jonction avec
le non-basse la Crimée et ensuite même
de pousser plus à l'ouest vers la ville
d'Odessa cette fois-ci qui est la
troisième ville du pays où apparemment
des premiers tirs ont commencé peut-être
de premier bombardements parce que si
les Russes s'emparent donnaient ça donc
troisième ville du pays et bien là c'est
une continuité territoriale totale le
long des côtes des côtes ukrainiennes et
il domine non seulement la mère d'Azov
mais le débouché de l'Ukraine sur la mer
Noire merci beaucoup Bruno